[Musique]
et donc il est très important que le
français qui a été historiquement
associé aux États-Unis plutôt aux élites
de la côte est soit représentée par une
école telle que nayfax dans un quartier
populaire qui est un quartier où vivent
des familles africaines américaines des
familles West africaines c'est la
témoigne de la vitalité culturelle et
multiculturelle de notre langue c'est
donc une très bonne nouvelle que
l'extension de l'impact on appelle
Harlem petit Sénégal donc ce nom a toute
une signification parce que le Sénégal
était un pays francophone donc c'est
dire que dans cette zone il y a un
potentiel
d'immigrants venant d'Afrique de l'Ouest
centrale venant des pays francophones de
façon générale donc une école comme
celle-ci a pour mission de servir
tous les potentiels migrants mais aussi
d'exposer les noms francophones n'est ce
pas à l'apprentissage de langue
française parce que nous nous croyons
fermement qu'être bilingue est un atout
n'est-ce pas particulier pour tout être
humain et pour tout leader